remember when mass effect 3 surprised us  with its awesome multiplayer mode  Bioware wants to mix it up again with  Andromeda I'm Tony and this game spot  news update is out of this world Mass  Effect Andromeda small t player is tied  to the game's main story although  Bioware isn't being too specific about  how just yet but the team doesn't want  to force you into playing it if you  don't want to you can send your crew out  to do side missions or take a hands-on  approach yourself by playing multiplayer  you can expect the same combat and array  of powers when you jump in but this time  around multiplayer will be much more  mobile with enemies that force you out  of cover and jetpacks to maneuver to new  places Mass Effect Andromeda is slated  for ps4 xbox one and pc and spring 2017  and we're just a few days away from  seeing new gameplay at the game awards  keep an eye on gamespot for that for all  the biggest mass effect news you're  already in the right place